yeah cuz I I mean I'm seeing this on
crown.com myself right now and the
actual translation portion if you don't
read the actual words they say that
they've taken their rabbis and monks as
well as the Messiah son of Mary Did You
See How They added as well did you see
how they added as well that's crazy yeah
they are literally they this is like I
said earlier they have to lie in the
English translation to deceive non
arabic speaking Muslims unfortunately
say with all the respect to you like you
because you don't know Arabic yeah I'm
definitely going to uh like look into it
that is very interesting I don't know
why that's done there may or may not be
a reason for it and that's I will
definitely look into it aliia how are
you hi can you hear me I can hear you
just fine welcome hi yeah so um I just
wanted to say I'm personally a revert
probably reverted about 3 years ago
after atheism then agnosticism you can
like question me on why but um one thing
that I I know about like Huffs and this
concept of like his untrustworthiness
versus you know and what they say and
him being a liar the untrustworthiness
comes from like his Hadith he's
untrustworthy in Hadith but he's not
untrustworthy in Quran recitation which
is what they mean by that and this
concept of him being a liar isn't that
he's not means to be a liar but they
call him a liar when it comes to Hadith
he's not they're not saying that he
knowingly lied though but that's because
they're very like strict about Hadith
who told you that who told me this yeah
here I'll show you like hold on okay so
let me just tell you what the scholars
actually say so they call him a liar and
the person the person person who's
calling him a liar is telling you why
he's a liar because he fabricated yeah
let's that actually work better we'll
just show like this so let's just go all
right right here okay the second to last
nameb says he's a liar he's rejected why
is he a liar because he fabricates
Hadith so sounds like a purpose but
reason for why he's called a liar the
reason why he's called a liar is because
he fabricates Hadith he makes Hadith up
that's why he's liar and he's also a
thief he's a thief so he's a liar he's a
thief a fabricator but yet you trust him
for Quran so I personally have not heard
the the point that he's a thief but my
question is like he was rejected sure
but he's fabricating Hadith is it yeah
he's knowingly doing so or is it that
that's what fabricating means
fabricating me things up you're
distorting it it's not saying he he
accidentally made a mistake it's saying
he's a liar why CU he fabricates Hadith
yeah there's a difference between being
mistake being Aken and lying you know
yeah you lie that's something
intentional no I understand what you
guys are saying I really do I understand
so why would you accept Quran from him
if he's a liar and by the way you said
you weren't familiar with the one about
him being a thief yeah that's no problem
we'll give you that we'll give you that
reference as well so it's actually alari
narrates this as well and it says
H blah blah blah they narrated him y
informed me
said took a book from me and did not
return it he said he used to take
people's books and copy them so Huffs
was one student of of awesome and Sh was
another student HS used to take his book
and and not return it and you take other
people's books and copy them meaning
like I'm copying them like as if they're
mine no I see what you're saying yeah
yeah interesting well I'm personally I I
would have to do my own research on it
so I'm going to go back in the Stream
and look at all these sources and do
more research towards it I mean that's
what I'm kind of like my goal is to do
proper research but then like my
question to you is were you guys born
Christian or did you choose Christianity
we choose Christianity yeah we all have
our own testimonies we all chran what
was like the one thing about
Christianity that you know first I guess
sparked your interest and then proved it
to be accurate for me it was Muhammad so
you use like another but like what is it
about Christianity I guess that proved
it not by using like another religion to
deny it Christian what makes you say
that the original Quran the origal
used to preach the gospel in Arabia
until they corrupted his uh story but
Muhammad was illiterate according to the
corrupted story he wasn't illiterate
truly okay where did you get this story
from like I don't mean any disrespect
I'm just I want to do like my own
research you find this it's fair to it's
fair to challenge me on that like you
know where do I get this from I got it
from the like the original Quran before
it was corrupted byman and what is the
original Quran where could I find this
Source personally it's been corrupted
like how do you find it Well we don't
have it today there's there's remnants
of of it like in the Quran that exists
today but okay but what sources did you
use to come up with this conclusion then
like where could I find this conclusion
then so like what what agrees what's
what's in the Quran that agrees with the
gospel and the Torah that we have that's
how we know that those are the parts
that are not corrupted the parts that
disagree we know that those are those
been corrupted by utman if you want to
go straight to where the Quran was
corrupted by utman that's sahkari 49
yeah yeah I know about that argument but
I mean like so then couldn't use that
same logic towards the corruption of the
Bible in the Torah way in what in what
way like we use the parts of the Quran
that align with the Bible in the Torah
the same way that you said you did so to
prove the quran's corruption do you
think that that is a a good method to to
judge whether is corrupted or not I
think it's similar to the method that
you use though because I believe right
that or there's other Muslims that also
believe I mean most Muslims we all
believe that like the Bible is corrupted
so I mean we could use the Quran to come
up with that assumption and conclusion
though and
use the Quran to come up with that
assumption as well you're very
intelligent so so do you believe that
the method that I amusing to judge
whether your Quran is corrupted whether
whether the parts agree with my Bible or
not do you think that that is a good
method to use it's a good question let
me think so you're saying that you use
the Quran to judge the Bible I use the
Bible to judge the Jud Quran that's the
same thing that we do with the Quran
right I think the Bible's corrupted so I
couldn't do that in turn yeah so I'm
saying that that the parts that I this
is how I know when you when I talk about
this original Quran and I say you ask me
where is it I say well it's been
corrupted you say how do you know how do
you make this judgment and I say
whatever agrees with the Bible that's
the good parts that's the preserved
Parts the parts that disagree with the
Bible those are the corrupted parts do
you think that that's an honest and good
method to use to judge whether something
has actually been changed and corrupted
no I don't know because now it has me
conf confused cuz here is the thing
right I see on both sides Muslims and
Christians doing this to themselves
right like for example Muslims use
Muslims say that the the gospel that the
Quran says and talks about is like the
inil it's not the same Bible we have
today so in turn I couldn't use that
same argument that you're using towards
any of my things and similarly I I
couldn't I don't know to me it just it's
it's very confusing right like coming
from a side you have to understand like
my perspective and how I came to
religion and the reason I chose Islam
versus Christianity because I did
Research into Christianity and I'm I'm I
would consider myself open-minded but
there was a lot of contradictions and
it's illogical so tell me so tell me and
I want you to be straight and honest
with me do not fear that you would hurt
my feelings I'm a tough cookie yeah what
I said and how I think the Quran is
corrupted and what parts I I take and
what I choose not to take based on the
Bible was that is that position
absolutely ridiculous does it sound like
dumb no I don't think it sounds dumb
because that's what Muslims do towards
the Bible that doesn't mean it does it's
a it ain't dumb that's yeah CU that's
now where it's like now I'm like
thinking well are both sides dumb that's
where I want to find the truth right
where do I find the truth kind of like
the mission that I'm on is to figure out
the full truth so so this is this so
this is the point so because because
you're you're you you kind of you get it
so it will be that it will mean that
both sides are dumb because that method
is ridiculous and that's kind of what
I've come up to the conclusion myself as
well because I actually watched your
video I actually have a whole Google
that I created for the video in which
yeah yeah I don't know if I can share my
screen but um you can if you push
present let me pull up the Google Docs
real quick on my thing okay and then
I've never done this before so give me a
second so I go to the yeah so just push
push present like uh it gives you
options down at the bottom of the screen
you yeah and then okay perfect it's not
going to show my whole screen will it oh
no no no I think I can choose yeah you
can choose you can choose what window
okay perfect okay can you see this all
right yeah there you go yeah so I'm
actually so like I'm creating like this
whole me trying to prove the quran's
accuracy and then similarly I'll do the
same thing with the Bible later on and
then come up with the complete truth on
what's from my findings and then
hopefully one day get it scholarly
accredited but I actually watched your
video on the Quran proves the
authenticity of the Bible in the Torah
and I wrote the Christians argument the
evidence used to back up the claim then
the Muslims counterargument then back to
the Christians argument then the
evidence used to back up the claim and
so on so forth and W now my goal is to
with the evidence that you use figure
out like I don't know I wrote like some
side notes and stuff about this so this
just leads me to ask because this is
actually beautiful what what do you
think of the argument that from that we
use from the Quran yeah actually so okay
my personal thoughts was okay so the
argument was the Quran says it's
confirming not just the Torah and the
gospel of the past but it's also
confirming and the gospel that we have
in our possession and the evidence used
to back up the claim was 2:41 which says
believe in my Revelations which confirm
your scriptures do not be the first to
deny them or trade them for fleeting
gain and then so on so forth the other
one says when there came to them a book
from Allah which recognized to
confirming the scripture they had in
their hands this has to be talking about
the Torah because the Bible was not in
their hands at this time so yeah this is
where I am confused myself because it
does at first hindsight appear to be a
contradiction but that's now my goal is
to prove wrong and if I'm not able to do
so then that means that the the Quran
cannot be wrong because if I can find
even a single contradiction in the Quran
then that must mean it's wrong because
it can't be from God I I am I you you
have no idea but you're getting me
extremely excited about about this
because the way that you're going about
this one it's honest it's intellectual
and yeah thing like I'm I'm not going to
be I'm not going to let you like I've
heard this argument from Christians who
tell me to pray to Jesus so I can find
the PATH out of no disrespect I refuse
to do so because in my belief I would
rather just pray to God and if Jesus Is
God then Jesus would show me the path
versus if I were to put Jesus in God's
like in front of God then I would then
be committing a sin and the devil could
stray me away
or or you could do it like this in a way
where it you could just say Jesus if you
are the true God if you are God reveal
yourself to me and show me soly funny
about that argument though is as Muslims
we believe that if in our dreams we see
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam or any even Jesus then and they
have a face or even a light showing then
that's actually not the prophet that's
actually JY showing up in our dream
that's that's fine and all but see you
would have to judge it with what is
objectively true in what you're
observing so my see my my tactic isn't
as you see isn't just go ahead and pray
to Jesus and you know you'll get the
truth type of that's none of our tactics
we show the evidence that Islam is false
and Christianity is true and with an
open person when they're like okay I'm
doing my research then we also advise
them yeah pray to God ask him to guide
you if Jesus is the truth show me guide
me and you'll and he'll bring you to
that conclusion but that that's that's
that's further down yeah idea so this
idea about the Quran affirming the Bible
now in your it sounded like you kind of
you separate the Torah from the Bible
what what do you think the so here's I
know that like there's the first
testament the Torah is the first
testament the Bible is the New Testament
but with this specific verse um where it
says although they used to pray for
victory by the means of the Prophet over
the polytheist this is verse this is
chapter 2 verse 89 yes when there came
to them a book from Allah which they
recognized confirming the scripture they
had in their hands they rejected it so
may Allah's condemnation be upon the
disbelievers so this has to be talking
about the Torah because are you saying
that the Bible was around during Jesus
time absolutely yeah yeah absolutely so
number one so this isn't even talking
about Jesus's time this is talking about
Muhammad's time because notice how it
says but when a book came to them right
you know confirming to the confirming
what they had it's talking about the
Quran it's talking about how the Quran
came confirming what they have and and
yet they're still rejecting it I see
what you're saying yeah yeah so it's
talking about the Torah that was there
in the seventh century which was in a
collection of books which is in a Bible
yeah no I see what you're saying and
yeah it does look appeared to be a
contradiction but that's my goal right
is like try to prove it wrong go with it
like a spectacle mind like I'm not going
to sit here and agree with you because
because I'm not knowledgeable enough I
can't say I agree yes you are though are
you kidding me you you have the you have
the most J out of all the guests that we
have and we're not just say we're not
I'm gonna just ask ji is is she not does
she not have the most common sense that
we've had so far yeah out of all the
guests that we've had You' presented
that you've actually first of all you
researched the topic of the Stream
you've done some research into that
topic you said you're going to do some
more research and that's great but
you've shown us that yes you actually
have looked into this you've seen some
of the arguments and you've seen the
counterargument but then like you said
when you get presented other arguments
you look into that further so from I I
agree you've actually demonstrated that
you have obviously you showed us your
you know Google documents and things
like that that you have done immense
research on these topics and you know
there's one thing there's one thing
though I want you to clarify because
with this argument right with this
specific portion of the argument I agree
that it does seem to be a contradiction
but there's the other portion in which I
really couldn't understand where you
were coming from okay um I tried to but
to me it just didn't make sense so if
you could clarify that that would be
great but um anyway so the argument was
you talk about in specific how the ters
say that they pervert words from their
meanings or so the verse in itself says
so this is the Muslims counterargument
uh which is verse chapter 5: 13 but for
breaking their Covenant we can condemn
them and Harden their hearts they
distorted the words of the scripture and
neglected a portion of what they had
have been commanded to uphold you oh
Prophet will always find deceit on their
part except for a few but pardon them
and bear with them indeed Allah gives
doers anyways so the Christians Conor
argument was the T say that they pervert
words from their meanings or that they
change this is talking about the T in
general or that they change words from
the right places so this is saying that
they are misinterpreting the text and
distorting the meaning not that they're
changing and corrupting the text simply
distorting the meaning or
misinterpreting it doesn't that mean the
same thing though distorting the meaning
or misinterpret interpreting it whether
or not on purpose it's still changing
the meaning which is corrupting well
yeah so but it's how the the question is
what type of corruption is happening is
textual corruption happening or is
interpretive corruption happening that
interpretation then can go into the text
correct no because so the difference is
is that they're not they're not going
into the the Bible they're not going
into the Torah or into the inil and
changing words you know what they have
is they have the Torah and inil they
know what it says but they say something
other than what it says so they're just
what the text says they're
misinterpreting what the text actually
means thereby corrupting it but with
their tongues not scripturally like not
not scripturally okay okay I understand
the argument now I'm going to write that
down so that or I'll go back to the
stream and I'll for sure write that down
I would like come back to you then one
day if um if I am able to disprove this
and definitely have a debate oh for sure
then so I'm gonna tell you right now
with the way how you are and I'll do the
same thing with the Huffs the same thing
I'll research I I guarantee you that you
you will you'll be on my side one day
you'll see my book one day insh your
book is g to be titled what what led me
to Christ if you say see I still have to
come up with the truth but yeah I
appreciate your you guys' time and I
will do more research on that one thing
I would also just like to quickly
mention though is I I you guys were
talking about how we add address Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
our prayer so you guys were talking
about the which actually
it's no yeah
it's so it says like peace be upon you
oh Prophet we are addressing Prophet
Muhammad s Al wasallam but not in the
sense that you may think it's more we're
addressing him to allaha T to give
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is our blessings in turn we get
more blessings for doing so because we
love Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam so we would do the same thing
if if we were in jesus' time and if
Jesus was the last prophet so you
address Muhammad in your prayer but
you're not meaning to address him you're
just one no we are meaning to we're
addressing him to Allah wa tala though
not necessarily saying oh Prophet like
peace be upon you we're saying peace be
upon you oh Prophet we're saying this to
Allah subhana wa tala to give him peace
yeah so there are different actually
schools of interpretation on that and
some schools will say actually instead
of saying Al you you say you change it
to to Allah meaning like on so it's not
addressing him and the reasoning is
because like you can look up you know
you've SE like you done research if you
look like bow Phillips for example he
talks about this that there are
different Muslim you know traditions on
this that they say because Muhammad is
no longer like that's how they all agree
that's how the prayer started like
everyone agrees with that but then after
Muhammad died some of them switched it
and said oh instead of saying because
he's no longer with us we say Allah so
there are differences in Muslims on that
but the by and large the majority like
every all the schools that you're have
traditional St schools for example
they're all going to address Muhammad so
everybody but but but but there are
Scholars who see that it's a problem so
there are Scholars who admit that it's a
problem because you are addressing
Muhammad I see what you're saying yeah
yeah interesting yeah I don't know for
me personally being indoctrinate
indoctrinated into the religion or not I
take it as I or if this has anything to
do with that I'm hanafi so I'm I'm Sunni
and the way we take it is uh we are
giving him blessings to allaha we're
telling allaha to bless him is what we
mean by that and by doing so we
therefore get more blessings in return
by sending our blessings to Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
right okay yeah that's that's how they
explain it but there's still a problem
there which you already see but yeah so
yeah that's one of the issues what did
you think about the one about submitting
to Muhammad the other verse that we
brought up submitting to Muhammad in
full submission can you tell oh yeah
yeah okay can you bring that verse back
up actually I did I did yes Yes
actually someone who wanted to comment
on I don't know if it was you yeah I
might have actually I probably was I
actually had it pulled up I think I
changed it because you guys were talking
about other verses what was the verse
again was the number the chapter and the
number it's 4 chapter
465 okay one second I'm pulling it up on
my end okay okay so I'll start from 64
we only sent Messengers to obey by
Allah's will if only these Hypocrites
those Hypocrites came to you a prophet
after wronging themselves seeking
Allah's forgiveness and the messenger of
Allah prayed for their forgiveness they
would have been would have certainly
found a ever accepting of repentance
most merciful and then 65 says but no by
your lord they will never be true
believers until they accept you oh
Prophet as the judge of their in their
disputes and find no resistance within
themselves against your decision and
submit wholeheartedly
so this verse in specific is actually
talking about a specific event that had
occurred so I don't know if you guys
have read the have you guys read the
theu seed for it or if you guys could
pull up the yeah uh there was I forgot
who's who gives the story but they give
the story of uh I don't know if it was
Umar that ended up killing the dude so
another reason Rob Christian I think he
has some information he's requesting if
if he come up on this topic here brother
Rob God bless you rob hello God bless
you guys what's up yes man God bless by
the way Rob Christian just had a stream
on this topic like yesterday right or
two days ago yeah man I found a missing
piece finally recently guys I found a
missing piece why all other university
dumbed their old H qurans in 1924 in the
Nal River a recent discovery I was
shocked but uh I'll show it if moments
from now but you wanted me to answer a
question about someone uning someone
yeah remember the reason when uh on 465
you have to submit to every decision
Muhammad does right and then there was a
guy who didn't agree with what Muhammad
said he went to somebody else didn't
agree with him and then went to I think
Umar and then Umar killed him yeah so
basically he kept switching he went he
kept going there there there and then
finally Omar leadly beheaded him where
where is that where's that's what what
uh who gives that top there man let's
see I'll try who had it yeah
um I'm reading IB C on this and it does
say at the end om went to his house and
emerged from it holding aoft his sword
he struck the head of the man who
rejected the prophet's decision with the
sword and killed him consequently Allah
revealed so this is where it's talking
about there's two men who got into an
argument and they rejected the decision
of prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam which is why he was you know
yeah it's for chapter 4 I 65 6 65 yeah
so let's see all right yeah yeah here it
is it's right here I found it where she
yeah you find it okay yeah all right y
another reason in his T oh yeah make you
judge in in all disputes between them in
his tap Al Abu isak i ibraim y y y
recorded that darhar narrated that two
men took their dispute to the prophet
and he gave a judgment to the benefit of
whoever among them had the right the
person who lost the dispute said I do
not agree the other person asked him
what do you want then he said let's go
to Abu Bakr ass sadik the truthful right
guys ass sadik is like the truthful
right they went to so I guess he wasn't
you know satisfied with Muhammad's
answer but he trusts that Abu Bakr will
give a more truthful answer since he's
known to be truthful they went to Abu
Bakr and the person who won the dispute
said we went to the prophet with our
dispute and he issued a decision in my
favor Abu Bakr said then the decision is
that which the messenger of Allah issued
the person who lost the dispute still
rejected the decision and said let us go
to Umar bin katab when they went to Umar
the person who won the dispute said we
took our dispute to the prophet and he
decided in my favor but this man refused
to submit to the decision Umar asked the
second man and he concurred Umar went to
his house and emerged from it holding
Aloft his sword he struck the head of
the man who rejected the prophet's
decision with the sword and killed him
he did what wait he did what he killed
him
consequently so as a result Allah
revealed by no but no by your lord they
can have no faith so this uh this
happened because you got to submit to
Muhammad with no
resistance so it's it's not only enough
to only submit to Allah you have to also
submit to Muhammad that's true Islam
yeah or else you have no faith yeah so I
I can't comment on that in specific
because I'm not very knowledgeable on
that all I do know is I will say from
one Hadith that I read and I'm actually
trying to find the source of it right
now was similarly we know so Shan is
also considered your Satan Shan actually
asked Prophet mam to ask Allah t for his
forgiveness so we know that people have
in the past with other prophets as well
also asked them to ask Allah forgiveness
for them so this is a common thing it
didn't only happen during the time of
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaih
wasallam but sister that's not the only
thing even if you go to chapter 48 48
Ayah 9 it says that you have to do suban
Muhammad you have to glorify Muhammad
every morning and evening chapter 48
verse which one
48.9 n it's off topic you know I I'm not
sure if the host would you know but I
think it's along the same lines because
I I think this is so it says so that you
Believers may have faith in Allah and
his messenger support him and honor him
and glorify Allah morning and evening
false translation I mean this is you
know why it's false translation because
Allah has mentioned once and Muhammad is
only mentioned once in the Arabic so
they had to lie in English translation
because else it will gives it away what
the Arabic says the Arabic is very clear
let me read the Arabic and I want you to
listen how many times Allah is mentioned
and how many times Muhammad the
messenger is mentioned
listen which means to assist Muhammad in
battle right so Allah has mentioned once
and Muhammad is the last person in the
in the Ayah
right last person is the messenger and
the very first
verb gives it away to to assist Muhammad
in battle you have to the second verb is
you have to honor or respect Muhammad
and the last
one to the messenger glorify am every
morning and evening wow he's right and
where did you find this specific like
translation or Nar I'm an Arabic speaker
sister I don't need look let me let me
just show you so you pull up arberry
translation the arberry translation is
very uh close sorry okay I'll pull up
I'll show the English translation that
gets it right but look on the right side
here I I so this is what I did you so on
this app it gives you the roots you can
break down word for word right it gives
you that so I did that on chapter 48
ver9 here and when you break it down
word for word it's exactly what Rob said
so look that you may believe in Allah
and his messenger and honor him and
respect him and glorify him so how do I
access this app because that's looks
like it's quran.com but it's not the
same quran.com that yeah this is this is
actually Quran x.com I guess that's a
slight okay show you a close if you
allow me brother understand I'm a
non-arab speaker so I don't speak but
let me show you a very close translation
so you can see how they play sometimes
and deceive people like you with all du
respect sister in humanity they they
have to deceive else it's sure you agree
you cannot glorify anyone else you
cannot do suban to anyone else except
Allah but in the AR translation that I
have here in front of me it says that
you may be even Allah and his messenger
and suur him which means to assist him
and reverence him to respect or honor
him and that you may give him glory at
the Dawn and the evening so you see in
this translation they didn't add
Muhammad twice or Allah twice in the
translation to deceive so check this out
I have on the screen here this is and if
you look at the the very bottom he talks
about different readings different
they actually added in in these readings
they added in the word Allah they had to
add Allah in and you can only guess why
because it's problematic if you don't
add a la so the verse the way that you
guys have the verse today in all the
qurans it's like this this is I want to
highlight this part here okay this is
the part here we're going to highlight
this this is how it looks today okay one
word two words three words now go down
they used to add extra word what word do
they add on they added the word Allah
because it's so problematic without
Allah there because the praise goes back
to who to Muhammad these other other
readers of the Quran used to add the
word Allah in there multiple ones used
to add the word Allah because it's so
problematic without adding Allah you get
the praise brother it's not only
problematic you
have it's this complet add in they add
in the word Allah imagine that they
completely a whole new word because if
you don't have Allah then it goes back
to Muhammad so these and by the way
these readings here these were not
accepted like we mentioned earlier how
there is the seven then there's the 10
these are not a part of the seven or the
10 these are just readings that existed
but they weren't accepted as
authoritative but these readings added a
lot on there because it was so I think
because it was so problematic and so
you're saying these readings are not a
part of the the Kat no so what's what he
what brother jahi means is today half
Quran that you probably have in your
house or the mosque you go to literally
contains sh because pick any language
including the Arabic The last person in
this case Muhammad all the rest of the
words and in this case these three verbs
to assist Muhammad in battle I mean the
very first verb gives it away to who
because Allah does not need assistance
in battle right
so to assist him in battle to respect
Muhammad
to do Subhan to give Subhan
glorification to Muhammad every morning
and every evening so you Muslims must
glorify Muhammad if that's not sh then I
don't know what the meaning of sh is
associating partners with Allah which is
the highest form yes of sin
forgive yeah if that is truth then that
is sure but again I but you have to
understand I am not an Arab speaker or I
can read the Quran but don't understand
sister you don't know what shik means of
course no she's saying it is it
is I'm saying that that is the case
which I will do my you know more
research then yes that is sh of course I
did you write it down 489 oh yes and
actually I I will do the same thing that
I uh did with the other argument and I
will research this it's given me a lot
to think about for sure definitely look
into this one and we can give you many
sources from the grammatical side that
will create these sort of problems in
the Quran
yeah yeah what are the other sources I
just mean other verses other references
like I know what you're saying chapter 9
verse verse 31 verse 31 yeah this is
another one where G it gives a big
problem and you have to like completely
change the grammar in order to avoid
this problem okay and so what is the
issue with this one okay and in in 931
it's if you rely on just the Arabic
right it it puts Jesus as as Lord with
Allah so it says and they take their
rabbis and their monks as Lords besides
Allah whilei and the Messiah can I can I
show her the Arabic brother if you give
me the big screen yeah you you got it
let me see I don't see your screen oh
wait sorry let me share my screen so
forgive me here here's the screen I
still don't see it oh there it is yeah
Luke sister if we do it word for word
you see right this is quran.com chapter
9 31 okay they have
referring to the Jews and the Christians
they have taken the Jews and the
Christians have taken their
rabbis they
rabis their monks as
Lords besides or instead of
Allah and the Messiah so who are the
real Lords not the monks and the rabbis
the real Lords pay attention are Allah
and the Messiah
and the Messiah yeah cuz I I mean I'm
seeing this on crown.com myself right
now and the actual translation portion
if you don't read the actual words they
say that they've taken their rabbis and
monks as well as the Messiah son of Mary
Did You See How They added as well did
you see how they added as well that's
crazy yeah they are literally they this
is like I said earlier they have to lie
in the English translation to deceive
non-arabic speaking Muslims
unfortunately say with all the respect
to you like you because you don't know
Arabic yeah I'm definitely going to uh
like look into it that is very
interesting I don't know why that's done
there may or may not be a reason for it
and that's I will definitely look into
it yeah I have it written down so I
appreciate that my question is I guess
because now I guess you can see like the
you know the problem that I face now
because as someone who looked into
Christianity prior to looking into a
slum I logically and I mean no
disrespect from this but logically I was
not able to understand this concept of
one in being three in spirit three
person person yeah sorry yeah yeah no I
well the argument that I heard was one
in sorry three in spirit one in no yeah
it was one one being three persons three
persons I guess it's like the same
correct or I guess not the same so off
the bat already we can tell that you
haven't really put as much research into
Christianity as you have into Islam
because this is like a basic you know
definition of the Trinity and so if you
don't have that right and you said
you've looked into it which I don't one
and being three in spirit versus one and
being three in person well look we have
very specific ways of articulating the
Trinity it's a very very rigid language
that we use we don't go beyond certain
language and this is how it's been
through throughout Christian history so
what I'm saying is this is like saying
yeah I've done my research on on the
Quran I've done my research on Islam
Spirit David wood Kishi yeah no they
don't no they don't say three spirit I
can show you the YouTube video in which
I actually watched cuz I watched all of
Nabil keshi's testimonies cuz he was
supposedly ex-muslim turned Christian he
was he was an ex-muslim yeah he was so
by the way that's just one video that
you may have seen that might have said
that but if you ask David wood today
what is the definition of the Trinity
he'll tell you one being three persons
okay but can you explain that to me like
as a non like you know as a
non-Christian I'm saying what I'm saying
though is that off the bat though you
already demonstrated that you don't you
don't have you haven't done the research
on Christianity that's fair
have definitely not done like as much
research into Christianity as I have
Islam but as someone who would be
looking for Christianity what's your
best explanation of the Trinity so let
me give you an analogy I'll just work
with you with by way of analogy you see
that there's one qut on right okay so
one Quran but yet you have awesome you
have all these different readings of the
Quran so there's seven seven readers and
you have H you have you have Ador all
these different trans of the Quran which
say different things here and there so
there's there's seven there's 10 there's
14 but yeah there's only one Quran what
you say so so you're you're saying one
Quran but yet you have multiple texts of
the Quran but yet you're still saying
there's one Quran so one Quran doesn't
mean that there's one text of the Quran
what does one Quran mean so there's one
Quran I guess I wouldn't agree with you
that there's one Quran asked you and you
said you said yes well I no because I
was agreeing with your analogy because
you're saying there okay yes well then I
guess technically I don't believe that
there's one Quran of course not there
isn't one Quran so's let's let's work at
it from from this way with with the
Quran then you believe that there's one
God right there's one God and you
believe that this God has you believe
the Quran is eternal like uncreated yeah
okay so you have one God you have his
uncreated word and he also has a spirit
as well right okay so yeah so as a
Muslim you say that you're a monotheist
you believe in one God but this one God
has an eternal word and an eternal
Spirit okay so yeah just like in
Christianity very similar language would
you say we say there's the Father the
Eternal Word which is the Son and the
eternal spirit which is the holy spirit
so you would say yes there's Allah and
the Quran is separate from Allah but not
distinct from there's like language that
you guys have to
use yeah exactly it's like yes can I
interrupt for a second we have someone
in the chat who left Islam because of me
it seems many burgers says this will
stick with me forever and I learn it
from Rob Christian the root of muta is M
meaning death even the Islamic books
prove the crucifixion Rob Christian
brought me to Christianity Hallelujah
brother God bless you I'm praise the
Lord Contin brother that's the Holy
Spirit that's the Holy Spirit who led
you to Christian who you to Jesus praise
God yes so yeah so amen that's amazing
that's amazing news uh so I lost my but
I understand what you're saying I do
understand what you're saying but then
also coming up because maybe this could
be my downfall but I found that
logicality to me is very important right
and so that's why again that's why I
question Islam but also Christianity a
lot my main question is you say like
these are Jesus's words right but
they're not written by Jesus or not
really spoken necessar it's inspired
words like written that were inspired by
Jesus so I wouldn't say they're direct
and so how would I know that this is
direct word of God comparatively like
what I believe to you don't believe that
the Quran just like fell out of the sky
in book form right you believe that this
is spoken words and then it was
transcribed and written down yeah yeah
yeah so Jesus well first I mean I guess
you're talking New Testament right
you're just talking like the go New
Testament not not not Old Testament yeah
so like gospels specifically like like
the red letters of Jesus or something
like that yeah yes so so yeah Jesus is
speaking words and Jesus also gives a
promise and he says that the holy spirit
will bring to remembrance everything
that he said to his disciples so as they
are writing down his words they have the
Holy Spirit yes as you said it's
inspired word of God writing down
jotting down exactly as the holy spirit
moves them to write so so we have like
you can you know a lot of times people
say that yeah I I might say it a lot too
but I think we should be clear in the
language Gospel of Mark or Gospel of it
makes it sound like okay there's one
Gospel of Mark one Gospel of John
actually you can translate the Greek K
Kata like Kon for example according to
so The Gospel According to so there's
one gospel but it's according to Matthew
this one Gospel According to Mark
according to Luke so one gospel but you
have these four different perspectives
it's not four different gospels okay
okay I see I see what you're saying yeah
yeah yeah because I've always taken as
like different gospels right like
exactly because that's people like it's
not the intention but I get what you're
saying okay so then so then my question
is when did what is the best way for me
to to read the Bible because I get
confused I'm not going to lie like I get
confused because there's so right I go
to bible.com and there's like I don't
know 15 different books or something
around this there's so many different
books don't I won't quote a number you
mean commentaries or translations I can
search up bible.com right now so
translations no not necessarily
translations either but so I go to
bible.com right yeah so there's okay
yeah yeah so there's one Samuel two
Samuel one Kings two kings there's this
is the Old Testament Genesis Exodus oh
yeah these are different books in the
Bible yeah yeah so I guess where's the
best place to begin to understand the oh
yeah okay got you got you yeah so for
what we would recommend to you it would
be yes start in the gospel St in like
Matthew Mark Luke and John that's where
you want to begin and and John has the
you know most clear christology to be
honest with you John you think you think
John is more clear than Mark and Matthew
no no no that's not what I said I said
it's the most the deity of Christ Mark
of course Mark to you know what I used
to say the same thing Rob but recently I
man Marcus you go to watch Anthony
Rogers material on that Mark Mark
actually yeah but John is you know you
know most most will agree that JN is fil
filled yeah as a high high christology
say but man yeah yeah well I logic I
think that you can find it all
throughout um but yeah yeah let's so
let's just start for for her though
let's say okay let's start with the
gospel according to John you can start
you can start there gospel with John but
isn't that the the last one or is that
the first one like what is the order in
which wouldn't John be it's Matthew
maruk and John John yeah yeah so so why
should I start with the last first and
then make my way up what do you well
because because you were asking you were
asking specifically about where's the
for you the Divinity of Christ yeah
exactly exactly why okay so then that's
another question like I guess this is a
not a counter question but a following
follow-up question why is it that it's
most clear and John and not Matthew Mark
or well actually so so this is what I'm
saying that's why I said Rob Rob say I
say I say Mark is is on par with with
John if not maybe slightly more with the
when it comes to the DD of Christ
because Mark literally starts off by
saying that Jesus is the god of the Old
Testament Yahweh he starts off the first
three verses he starts that off and
makes and what's amazing in even in Luke
if you there's there's a book that I was
reading on this it's amazing study check
this out if you look in the Gospel
According to Luke and you look at all
the times he uses the word Lord cuos in
Greek in like the first two chapters the
usage is limited the Lord cuos Lord is
only ever used of like Yahweh and Old
Testament quotes and then of Jesus so
every single time in the first two
chapters you're going to see the word
Lord being used it's of Yahweh it's of
Jesus Yahweh Jesus so then you you come
to this conclusion I know yahweh's name
was yeah yeah I know that Jesus is
Yahweh um yeah so any gospel you want to
start any gospel you want to start with
whether it's Luke Matthew mark
John you're going to see a very clear
presentation of who Jesus is can we give
a quick let's do it you want to see a
quick example of this sure definitely so
we'll we'll we'll compare we'll compare
John one and Mark one let's do that side
by side and so you'll see you'll see why
most people like at first glance would
say oh yeah John yeah it's by far is the
clearest at first glance so let me just
pull this up real quick and let me show
the the other Mark all right Mark one
okay
okay got them both pulled up all right
oops man whose page is man get that off
my page all right here we go so we got
mark one and we got we got mark one on
the left John one on the right so we're
going to start with John one over here
and show you why first glance is it's
like it's John by far right so look so
it says this in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God so you already see here
that there's two persons that's being
identified as God one who's the word and
the the other person who's not named
specifically but they both have the
nature of God right okay he was in the
beginning with God so there's a
distinction he Al although he is god
with with this person there's also a
distinction in their personhood like
he's not that same person but they share
the same Essence the same nature as God
so he was in the beginning with God all
things were made through him and without
him not anything made without him was
not anything made that was made so the
word is God who was the agent by which
everything was right so this is what it
says then about the word let's just drop
down to the 14th verse and the word
became flesh and dwelt among us and we
have seen his glory glory as of the only
son from the father full of grace and
truth so now we know who the word is and
we know who he was with in the beginning
it's the son and it's the father right
right so according to this it's pretty
clear that both the father and the son
are God right John 1 yeah no I know yeah
I agree right so usually you know people
like they read John one and by the way
John one is is it's a beautiful verse
like if we continue it's it's it's
beauti beautiful chapter I mean let's
see let's keep going it says John bore
witness about him and cried so this is
John the Baptist not John who wrote the
Gospel but John the Baptist his cousin
Jesus his cousin John bore witness about
him and cried out this was he of whom I
said he who comes after me ranks before
me because he was before me okay so this
John the Baptist who is the older cousin
of Jesus in the flesh but it's saying
that Jesus existed before him so he
ranks before him right so for from his
fullness we have all received Grace upon
Grace for the law was given through
Moses Grace and Truth came through Jesus
Christ no one has seen ever seen God the
only God who was at the father's side he
has made him known so watch this so this
is saying no one has se ever seen God
meaning the Father the only God who is
at his side which is the son he has made
him known made the father known so what
this is saying is that the father is God
and the only God you're saying they're
referring to referring to Jesus who is
at the father's side he has made him
known yes okay I see what you're saying
he has revealed the father he's revealed
revealed God to us right so so this is
John one pretty clear indisputable this
is John one or this is this is John John
one this is John so you can see why
someone be like oh yeah if you want to
see the Divinity of Christ go go
straight to John if you want to see it
more clearly actually I know a lot of
Muslims make this argument saying the
Divinity of Christ started at John not
yeah exactly they try to say that this
this idea developed over time right they
try to say that John's late gospel you
know with it being late had time to
develop ideas and develop this idea of
Jesus being God when in the beginning
the earlier gospels did not have this
idea which so where where where is this
idea in the earlier gospels like can you
mark for example so that's why I said
Mark so we go to Mark chapter one now
Mark according to you know some liberal
most liberal Scholars is the earliest
gospel well if you go to church history
it'll be Matthew but it doesn't matter
let's go with Mark because they they say
Mark let's say so Mark's the earliest
Gospel According to them okay so this is
it starts off the beginning of the
Gospel of Jesus Christ the son of God as
it is written in Isaiah the prophet so
this is what we're going to do so on
this side I'mma to put up Isaiah what he
quotes I'm actually put both of them up
because he quotes both Isaiah and
Malachi so we're going to do Isaiah
40 ver 3 to 5 because this is what he
quotes and then we're also going to do
Malachi 3 3 one okay all right so here
we are over here in Mark he says as it
is written in Isaiah the Prophet or some
man should just say the prophet so it's
written in the prophets behold I send my
messenger before your face who will
prepare your way the voice of one crying
in the wilderness prepare the way of the
Lord make his paths straight so Mark is
quoting about Jesus is quoting Isaiah
and the prophets saying that there's a
voice in the wilderness that's going to
prepare his way prepare the way of the
Lord right now so is that voice the Holy
Spirit no right here it tells us right
here so the voice crying in the
wilderness the one who's in the
wilderness preparing the way for the
Lord to come who is this verse four John
appeared baptizing in the wilderness and
proclaiming a baptism of repentance for
the Forgiveness of sins and all Jud all
of the country of Judea and all
Jerusalem were going out to him and were
being baptized by him in the River
Jordan confessing their sins Okay so
this is John who was in the wilderness
preaching and preaching a baptism of
repentance telling people to repent turn
to the Lord he's preparing the way for
the Lord okay now let's drop down to
verse 7 and he preached saying after me
so John is the one who's in who's the
voice in the wilderness and he's now
talking about someone who he's preparing
the way for someone coming after him
after me comes he who is mightier than I
the strap of whose sandals I am not
worthy to stoop down and untie I have
baptized you with water but he will
baptize you with the Holy Spirit and
then who is it that comes in those days
Jesus came from Nazareth of Galilee and
was baptized by John in the Jordan okay
okay so and then we continue and when he
came up out of the water immediately he
saw so John saw the heavens being torn
open and the spirit descending on like a
dove on him like a dove and a voice Came
From Heaven you are my beloved Son with
whom I am well pleased so this is so
John is the one whose the voice in the
wilderness crying out and who is he
preparing the way for sister for Jesus
for Jesus however now let's see when we
go to Isaiah which is what he quotes
Mark quotes it who is the voice of the
Wilderness preparing the way for here it
is a voice cries in the wilderness
prepare the way of the Lord and in all
caps you see how it's all caps like this
it means Yahweh in the Hebrew and coming
from someone who doesn't know so like
where okay how do you get that so like
for example let me just open up a tab
here and show you in the Hebrew I don't
know I honestly guys do you have any
insight on why they don't just put
Yahweh there why they do it's basically
it's a it's a Jewish tradition that is
uh adopted like by the seent and when
the New Testament quotes the septent
it's quoting like an already existing
Greek translation where instead of
saying Yahweh because they they viewed
that as two sacred to pronounce instead
of saying Yahweh they would say okay say
Lord say Adonai like today you'll say
Jews they'll say like Adonai or Hashem
they won't say the name Yahweh because
they think it's too sacred so so that's
basically just like a tradition but
there are some Bibles that are trying to
go back and actually whenever it says
you know Yahweh in the Hebrew they try
to say it in the English as well so some
translations do try that but that's
that's basically the reasoning behind it
so you see here I got the Hebrew pulled
up on wasn't Jesus's name Yeshua yeah so
I know like Christians believe he was
Yahweh but um yeah are you saying Yeshua
and Yahweh are the same person well
Yeshua specifically the son is is Yahweh
so Yahweh is is God okay so it's the
same okay so the same concept so we call
him Jesus but he's still God you're
exactly exactly so so you see here in in
uh so I pull it up Isaiah 40 this is
verse three and right here where it says
Lord in the English and and on the right
side really when you go to the Hebrew
it's Yahweh okay okay right and so the
voices so now going back over to the
right side in the wilderness prepare the
way of the Lord which is Yahweh prepare
the way of Yahweh make straight in the
desert a highway for our God so
according to Isaiah who is the voice in
the wilderness preparing the way for
Alia John well no so John is it's
preparing it for Jesus
though exactly if you were to ask Isaiah
who would Isaiah say who who would
Isaiah say is the one who's coming the
one in the Wilderness is is preparing
the way for who God exactly okay he's
preparing the way for God okay so if so
you see how now let's continue like
verse four every Valley shall be lifted
and every mountain and Hill be made low
the uneven ground shall be shall become
level and the rough place is plain a
plain and the glory of Yahweh shall be
revealed and All Flesh shall see it
together for the mouth of Yahweh has
spoken so the one who's coming is God
himself and the one who's preparing the
way for God God to come is John the
Baptist who's the voice in the
wilderness so Mark immediately in the
very first few verses of his of his of
his gospel what the verse the first uh
three verses he identifies Jesus as
being Yahweh of the Old Testament okay I
see I see I see now see the now the
reason why John will be a little bit
more easier for let's say the
non-Christian is because you know in
John it was just like straightforward
type of you know you don't gotta go and
look at the Old Testament to see what's
being talked about you know a lot of it
has to do with a lot of it has to do
with like familiarity with with the Old
Testament and so like if you like coming
from a non-jewish background so you
don't have familiarity with the Old
Testament then you might not catch these
references right away but the original
audience who's reading this they're
going to be oh yeah it's here here here
and here wow they're going to get it
right away because they had familiarity
but if you go to Mark chapter 5 this is
another example Mark chter 5 this is
when a demon-possessed man was healed by
Jesus and this is like the the famous
story when Jesus tells the demon the
unclean Spirit to come out and he says
what is your name he my name is Legion
for we are many and so this is that
story there now if you if you keep
calling down to verse like 19 Verse 18
verse 19 to verse 20 it's while he uh
yeah there you go right there so can you
zo in something yeah yeah as he was
getting into the boat the man who had
been possessed with demons begged him
that he might be with him and he did not
permit him but said to him go home to
your friends and tell them how much the
Lord has done for you so go home and
tell them what the Lord has done for you
go tell them what God has done for you
and how he has shown mercy on you then
it goes on to say and he went away and
began to reclaim in the
umis how much Jesus I'm getting tongue
twisted going Arabic Hebrew and English
Greek yeah the Deus how much Jesus had
done for him how much Jesus so go and
tell What the Lord Has Done go and tell
what God has done and then it says he
went on and told what Jesus had done so
this is another clear example where
Jesus is being presented as the Lord as
God yeah and I see what you're saying
yeah I do see what you're saying I think
where I definitely want to like read it
myself doubt I think like it's it's
really important to do so I think anyone
should before they choose what the right
path is but my question is why is it so
like ambiguous why is no like no it's
not it's not ambiguous sister again like
like what J said I mean it's not
ambiguous but why is it not so like
clear and front forward like you know
like saying like Jesus Is God versus
like you know well well well it is like
so for example if if you are if you know
what the Old Testament says if you know
what the prophet said here you know this
this is this is as clear as it get it
doesn't get any clearer than this when
you say that Jesus is the one who was
coming who he's the Lord who is having
his way prepared he's Yahweh it don't
get know right everybody is in to know
right but you know you do have other
ones that are like you know straight up
you know Jesus is God but saying saying
saying Jesus is Yahweh is more powerful
than just saying Jesus Is God you know
everybody's claiming to be God around
you know Caesar and all them they're
claiming to be God the Romans they have
their
God but if you are claiming if if the
author is saying he's Yahweh he is the
god of Abraham Isaac and Jacob that
right there is bigger than just saying
yeah Jesus Is God way bigger you know
but let me just show you just for for
your you ask you know for something
that's like like that let me show you
and so and so this this name of God
Yahweh when you see it in the Old
Testament like like I mentioned the
Jewish tradition was okay because this
name is too holy it's too sacred we
don't want to say it in vain so instead
of saying Yahweh we're going to say Lord
and so when you see Lord being used
throughout the New Testament it's
primarily applied to Jesus and so anyone
who's reading that with Old Testament
eyes like you're thinking wow that's
Yahweh that's the Lord like in Matthew
you know we're talking about Mark right
now but in Matthew Jesus says why do you
say to me Lord Lord whenever you see
Lord Lord being used and also it's in
Luke
6:46 I think got to double check it 646
he says you know why do you call me Lord
Lord but not do what I say so why do you
call me lord lord lord lord every single
time that's used in Old Testament is
referring to Yahweh and Jesus applies to
himself right there so so like we're
saying it's like it's not that it's not
clear it's just that some of us we don't
have that Old Testament background
context when we're reading it and once
we get that context it's like whoa the
lights's on it's really clear and
brother J I want to add something since
brother Avery likes the mark uh Gospel
of Mark so much I will use Mark no
problem brother Avery if we go to Mark
and if I can get the big screen for a
second brother logic look if we go to
mark 11:3 this is the story about Jesus
asking his disciples to go get him a uh
a cult so and he says to his disciples
if anyone asks you why are you doing
this say the Lord needs it and will send
it back here shortly so what does Jesus
call himself the Lord to make it more
clear from an Islamic point of view to
you if if we go to sister for chapter
one of the
Quran ayat number two it says
alhamdulillah right you know this ay
right yes yes if we go down in the of
which you see here on the screen
literally look what it says so keep in
mind Jesus in Mark 11:3 he called
himself the Lord with
the the Lord with a definite article
also in Arabic then it says here in cath
he explains
himself says that you cannot
use the with a definite
article except for
Allah you can call yourself for example
Lord of your house Lord of this but you
cannot use the Lord with theam with the
definite article except for Allah but
Jesus in Mark 11 he calls himself the
Lord bless brothers and sisters can I
add kind of like you know like want to
what brother Christian said is it okay
yeah and by the way guys it is getting
we're at the three- hour mark so go
ahead Al this will be this and I think
that we've given the sister enough we
don't to over yeah I really appreciate
it but you will hear back from me I hope
you know you will definitely hear back
from it I hope so I last time I bet
you'll have a new uh page or new file
that you have on this stream this on top
no yes I will actually definitely will
Ali A Daughter of Christ yeah good good
to meet you Ali you know Brothers as
well
just wanted to say something you know
like I'm an ex-muslim Ali as well you
know I came to Christ and you know today
know him as as my Lord and Savior you
know like when I was reading the gospels
right like there's four gospels and I
had the same question like why there's
four like why there's not one you know
but I was just blown away the Beauty and
the power of the gospels like how it's
actually like into the into harmony like
uh for the Life of Christ like an
example I just want to add just because
you know that's a topic you know if you
read the Matthew right Matthew presents
Jesus as the Messiah and the king and
primarily like he's trying to explain
that to the Jews because the Jews they
know the Torah they know the the the
previous scriptures right not the not
the not the Romans they don't know that
not the people who are Gentiles as well
they don't study the Torah and all that
so when you read the Matthew I was blown
away because I was like like as a as an
ex-muslim like uh when I was a Muslim
like one thing I heard from Christians
was like you know that that is
impossible for Jesus
to put those you know like like those
prophecies fulfilled if you if if he was
just a mere man but for somehow this
beautiful prophecies just comes and
aligns in the life of Jesus like like I
I went over like 400 of them like with
my with one of my friends and I was just
blown away and that's what Matthew tries
to kind of show us that he always brings
Matthew always brings the Old Testament
prophecies writings and practices and
connects beautifully even like when he's
trying to explain you know all the the
customs and like that's why when the the
the Jewish you know Believers study the
Bible study Matthew they blown away as
well the mark in the other hand is like
it's concise it's kind of like you know
brief and it's like abrupt and you know
you can see that it's like to the point
like you know the god logic was
explaining like how just like
immediately goes tells you that who
Christ is right he's God he's the Lord
but at the same time he talks about you
know the his servanthood and that's to
the mind of the Greeks right because
when you read the Greek Unos sources
it's concise all the time you have to be
to the point as well like the Western
mind kind of thing right I don't want to
you know like speak like I can speak
like a lot about this but I don't want
to do that but when you read the look
right look being a doctor as well and
that's uh that's also like primarily you
know written to the Greeks as well but
like in a sense that every detail is
very important for look right he goes
into details about Jesus humanity and
just kind of makes sense right but the
last one like the you know the when I
when I say Greeks I'm talking about the
Gentiles it could be us as well because
you know we're not the you know the the
the Jewish people right and and the last
one John was kind of like you know blows
away because it's for the all the
Christians you've got the the whole
world is covered the Jewish the primary
you know the the people that came to and
then the Romans but who was the you know
people who are in ruling and then the
third is the the the Greeks and the
Gentiles and the last one is the all the
Christians and when I read uh you know
all those four gospels and even you know
in Islam you know that you have to have
the four testimonies right like to
something to be valid but you know the
point is even in all the Testament as
well but the point is it is so in
Harmony and it just blows you away it's
so beautiful that's that's what I just
wanted to say yeah so that's good we're
going to wrap it up here Aliyah thank
you so much for the conversation really
apprciate it guys you by far was the
best guest that we had today